DRONE.
SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEOLU SMOKE DOWN
LONE LOWE INDICATION, BROKEN
WINDOWS INE E ER GROUP, YEVGENY
PRIGOZHIN SAID HIS GROUP'S NE
ORY.
IN THE LATEST N G
PUBLIC FIELD WIT,
OFFICIALS TOTHEREFENSE OFFICIA
ISMMTEIME.R WEEKS PRIGOZHIN HAS
SSDERSHI APPRODUCE W
DRESSES UP LIKE ON Y
ATCKIA'S TOP GALON IS WH I
MELISSA BELL LOO
MANNED BUL
ARY GROUP.
RONTHW PRIGOZINTH
IGHT.
BEEVMILITARY.orAL E ANNOD E WIAW
WAGNER MEARST
WEERG TH
RUSSIAN ADVANCE IN UKRAINENTHSPS
POLITICAL NFTH  MORE
LONG KNOWN BY HICKNAME AS CHEFEB
NEIGHBORHOODS OF ST. PETERSBURG
VAST CATERING .
AS PUTINETIS ND EASTEN OZ WE
ER MERCENARY GROUP THA
ECAME , OPERATING
THIS THE
BUT ITE S OF INVASION OF UKRAINE
FLINR
WHH HED LO AGAIN NSOP
LINE
OSGHT THE
WAR FAR CL
CO
"YOU ARE THENSE.A O
WHY E LOWING THESE
Y TO MOSCOW?"
BECAUSE PRANS ARGUABLY RIGOZH D
WHICH  PUMPING OUTUNE
U.S. PRESIDENTIAL ECIGOZHIN WASB
U.S. DESPITE DENYING ANY
NOW HE IS PERSONALLYAKINOPAGAND
AND SS RUSSIA,UR
ATTENTION TO WHAT HE CALLS THE
ENAT HOME, WITH CRPO
HIS OWN.
TEM WAS STABLE,
THWAS NO PLACE FOR HIM AND WAIT.
AN THE SYSTEM
D HE FOUND
THE SYSTEM.
orter: AND RUSSIA'S
POLITIL SY, JUST LIKE ITS
APPEARS TO BE SOMETHINGISER.to
IN ON, JUST LIKE INE SOIE WILD
THEIR LOVED ONES
RUSSIAN SOCIETY MAY BE FORLVE TL
A MESSAGE EVENORE HARDAN THAT OE
. VCHVE BEEN SO MANON MONTHS TH
REBUKEROADIMIR PUTIN, EVEN
OF
CRITICISM  THE
PRIGOZHIN IS HIMSELF FAR
HARDLINE EVEN THANDIMIR
PUTIN.
IFT P ,
WOD ONY SEMBRACY, AN
VENEER WOULD BE SWEPT E IN
THE F WIG  E VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
PROBLEM.
AN CRACKING DOOT T ALEXE MORDERR
ENNGN S LIKE
SO IN A SE
WITH A MAN ON WHOM H
TO DEPEND IN